[Musique]
depuis des milliers d'années les hommes
suivent carte rumeurs légendes et autres
fantasmes à la recherche de trésors en
or certains convoite la richesse
d'autres le pouvoir d'autres encore la
beauté ou bien carrément un signe divin
prêt peut résister à la très envoûtant
de l'or
la plus ancienne quête que l'on
connaisse d'un trésor constitué d'or
demeure un mystère dans la bible l'exode
nous apprend que dieu a remis à moïse
ses dix commandements sur le mont sinaï
sur deux tablettes de pierre celle ci
était maintenu dans une pièce secrète
faite de bois d'acacia recouvert d'or
cette relique n'est autre que l'arche
d'alliance véritable clé de voûte de
l'histoire des légendes les plus tenaces
sur les trésors disparu au 10ème siècle
avant jésus-christ le roi salomon fait
bâtir à jérusalem un temple afin d'y
abriter large
c'est dans ce sanctuaire fermé appelé le
saint des saints que repose quatre
siècles durant
l'arche ainsi que d'autres trésors en or
archéologue spécialiste de l'histoire
biblique vend-il jones a consacré sa vie
à suivre la piste de l'arche d'alliance
l'arche d'alliance le ménorah le
chandelier à sept branches et l'hôtel de
l'encens notamment ainsi que tous ceux
qui équipait le tabernacle le sanctuaire
itinérant de l'arche d'alliance et est
fait d'or pur au début du vième siècle
avant jésus-christ les babyloniens
envahissent jérusalem
selon la légende le prophète jérémie a
mis en sécurité les trésors du temple
dans une grotte secrète
jérémy a déclaré qu'on ne retrouverait
pas l'endroit avant que dieu ait
rassemblé son peuple pour l'accueillir
dans sa miséricorde
on trouve ce récit dans les apocryphes
une collection décrit anciens dont on
ignore l'origine alors qu'il lit dans sa
jeunesse le second livre des maccabées
jones voit son attention attirée par une
vague référence faite aux documents
révélant l'endroit où se trouveraient
les trésors cachés du roi salomon
c'est ce passage qui a retenu toute mon
attention et m'a fait partir à la
recherche de ces documents en 1947 une
étrange coïncidence tombe à pic
alors que l'état d'israël vient de
naître des bergers bédouins font une
découverte exceptionnelle au fond d'une
grotte près de la mer morte
les rouleaux manuscrit de cuir et de
papyrus vieux de 2000 ans quand ils ont
déniché en 1947 les manuscrits de la mer
morte
j'ai pensé que c'était peut être bien là
les écrits qu'on recherchait pour jones
la clé de l'énigme est un rouleau de
cuivre retrouvé dans une grotte de
qumran en 1952
huit ans plus tard la diffusion de son
contenu fait état de l'inventaire de
trésors considérable dans les ruines
doré bas dans la vallée d'accord pose
sous les marches qui se dirige vers
l'est une caisse d'argent pesant le
poids de 17 talent dans la tombe de la
troisième section de pierre vous
trouverez sans barres d'or
la signification de ce manuscrit de
cuivre est sujette à controverse chez
les spécialistes jones pense qu'il
s'agit là d'une carte au trésor
menant aux reliques d'or du temple de
salomon le rouleau de cuir dévoiler
l'endroit où étaient cachés les trésors
du temple ça correspondait précisément
aux révélations annoncées par jérémy et
les apocryphes en 1967 à qumrân jones
eux s'engagent sont les traces
légendaire de jérémy avec le manuscrit
de cuivre pour seule carte au trésor
j'ai passé les dix premières années à
essayer de repérer les lieux d'après les
descriptions géographiques fournies par
le document un lit de rivière asséchée
appelé rivière du dôme ainsi que la
caverne de la colonne constituent des
deux points de repère principaux
mentionné dans le manuscrit
pourtant aucune carte ne fait état de
leur existence
ce n'est qu'en examinant une
photographie aérienne de la région de
qumran que john se remarquent la
présence d'un lit de rivière qui ne
porte pas de nom
j'ai été voir mon conseiller peacock
gordon qui avait écrit un livre sur les
rivières du désert je lui ai demandé de
me dire le nom de cette rivière
il m'a regardé il m'a répondu qu'elle
n'en avait pas je me suis donc retrouvé
avec une rivière sans nom mais également
avec un non sens rivière c'est en
cherchant associer les deux que je suis
partie remonter le cours de cette
rivière dans un coude
j'ai découvert un passage surmonté d'un
arrondi parfait je tenais peut-être là
ma rivière du dôme marque quelques
instants plus tard jones pense avoir
identifié son second repère alors que je
revenais vers ma voiture en direction de
la mer j'ai aperçu en me retournant deux
magnifiques grottes a collées l'une à
l'autre
la grotte de la colonne
jones est convaincu d'avoir résolu deux
des minimes du manuscrit de cuivre
[Musique]
j'en étais déjà passé sur ma carte
lacroix fatidique qui marquent
l'emplacement du trésor et rien qu'avec
cette rivière et la grotte
j'avais déjà pour ainsi dire toucher au
but inutile de vous dire que ça me
rendait fou de joie
en vérité il n'en est qu'aux prémices de
ces recherches pendant 20 ans jones
fouilles énormément de grottes dans les
collines qui entourent qumran en avril
sa persévérance est enfin récompensé
dans l'une d'entre elle james trouve une
petite cruche contenant de l'huile
épaisse dont il pense alors qu'il s'agit
d'huile bénite utilisé pour consacrer
les rois d'israël
c'est une découverte capitale pour toute
son équipe
car le manuscrit de cuivre parle bien
d'une ligne d'options
grâce à ce que pouvaient appeler notre
carte au trésor
on était arrivé maintenant à localiser
trois des éléments mentionnés dans le
manuscrit en 1994
l'utilisation d'un radar capable
d'explorer le sous sol fournit des
résultats tout à fait spectaculaires
tout près c'est à dire environ 7 mètres
de la grotte
il en avait trouvé le manuscrit de
cuivre il y avait un autre accès
souterrain qui s'était effondré il
conduisait sous la grotte en la
contournant on savait que se cacher là
dessous une très importante cavité jones
est persuadé qu'il touche au but de
toute une vie et qu'il s'apprête à
exhumer l'arche d'alliance et les
reliques en or du temple de salomon
les théories développées par jones
peuvent être qualifiés d'original et
sont sujettes à controverse aussi
demeure-t-il dans l' attente d'une
autorisation fournies par les autorités
culturelles israéliennes pour mener à
bien ces fouilles sa quête se poursuit
toujours
trouver la fameuse arche reviendrait
pour lui à faire la plus grande
découverte de tous les temps et je
dirais même que le fait de découvrir
l'arche d'alliance et le tabernacle
n'aurait rien de comparable avec
d'autres découvertes d'envergure comme
celle de la tombe du roi tout parce que
ces objets sacrés vont à nouveau nous
servir et prendre leur place dans
l'avenir
par conséquent on ne fait pas que
creuser le passé on investit pour le
futur sur deux continents différents
deux autres cas typique ont lieu l'une
pour un homme en or l'autre pour une
ville dort on estime la valeur des
nombreux trésors dont fait état le
manuscrit de cuivre à 23 5 tonnes d'or
soit environ 230 millions de dollars
il y a quatre siècles et demi
une simple rumeur va inspirer l'une des
plus grandes chasses aux trésors de
l'histoire
l'enjeu de cette chasse les légendaires
cette cité d'or une véritable expédition
apparaissant comme la seule conséquence
positive d'une autre de ses ruée vers
l'or à s'être terminée de façon
désastreuse
tout commence en 15/100 28 alors que
plusieurs centaines de conti ce tas d'or
espagnol sont plongés dans les fourrés
de floride à la recherche d'or
harcelé par les indiens et souffrant de
maladies il passe huit ans à se frayer
un chemin vers les colonies espagnoles
les plus proches au mexique
quatre hommes seulement survivre aux
périls mais ils reviennent en faisant
miroiter une pépite terriblement
attrayante où la rumeur selon laquelle
nord de nos jours le nouveau mexique
serait plein à craquer de richesse
assoiffé d'or les espagnols du mexique
pense alors que ces miraculés ont
découvert cibola les légendaires cette
cité d'or le plus enthousiaste d'entre
eux est un noble de 28 ans donne
francisco vazquez des coronado si
coronado a manqué la conquête du mexique
et du pérou il estime que si beau l'art
est pour lui la chance d'acquérir gloire
et richesse dans le nouveau monde
en février 15 140
il quitte la ville de mexico à la tête
de 300 hommes
au printemps il traverse le grand désert
de sonora
le soleil tape si fort qu'ils cuisent
littéralement sous leur cuirasse et sont
incapables de toucher leurs épées son
chemin l'amener à travers le nouveau
mexique vers l'arizona
c'est la toute première fois qu'on
s'avançait sur cette terre qui viendrait
les états unis après cinq mois de
canicule
ils parviennent à la première ville du
nouveau mexique bien qu au bord de la
famine la nourriture n'est pas leur
première préoccupation leur premier truc
a été de se demander où est l'or se
trouve qu'il y a un aspect extrêmement
tragique dans cette poursuite
impitoyable du métal précieux
la ville palatial qui anime leur rêve
n'est autre qu'un poussiéreux villages
indiens du sud ouest il n'y a pas une
once d'or par ici quelques jours plus
tard coronado voit ses espoirs renaître
lorsque le prisonnier qui l'a fait d'une
tribu lointaine lui décrit une ville
d'or située à l'est est appelée qui vira
le roi il serait si riche qu'il faudrait
aux espagnols des dizaines de chars est
pour pouvoir les transporter tout son or
au delà de qui virent à il y aurait même
d'autres villes encore plus riche
coronado a entendu ce qu'ils voulaient
entendre
cela fait partie des pouvoirs de l'or
il lève immédiatement le camp vers l'est
sur la trace de qui vira dans la partie
septentrionale du texas
l'eau est si rare que ces hommes
s'alimente directement dans les trous de
vases qu'il croise chaque fois que
coronado lui demande jusqu'où faut-il
avancer pour trouver qui vira le guide
répond encore plus loin la cité d'or se
trouvait toujours de l'autre côté de la
colline et puis c'était encore après la
colline suivante où la rivière suivante
à la traversée des villages les
conquistadors se servent en nourriture
vêtements et fab ceux qui ont le malheur
de leur faire barrage sont exécutés afin
d'intimider les tribus voisines
les espagnols n'étaient pas nombreuses
mais c'étaient des cavaliers en armure
étincelante drapeaux au vent capable
d'effrayer et de faire taire à jamais
des milliers d'indiens qui était
traumatisée ne serait ce que par leur
apparence en étaient 15 141 coronado
parvient au texas actuelle il a
entre-temps capturer un deuxième guide
indien lequel contredit les affirmations
du premier la cité d'or ne serait qu'un
mensonge mais coronado préfère continuer
de croire en une promesse de richesse
dépassant ses rêves les plus fous
c'est une légende dont je dirais qu'elle
est très séduisante au stade le
personnage d'el dorado est né
précisément des reds utopiste et le
moteur de corona doit justement ce même
type de rêve
par un après midi de juillet 15 141 près
de sept mois après le début de leur
expédition
les espagnols aperçoive enfin une aura
d'auray qui flotte à l'horizon une
centaine d'édifices aux formes de ruches
étincelant sous le soleil
il ne s'agit que d'un cruel mirage ou de
simples et grossir huttes recouvertes
d'herbes âge qui réverbère de loin la
lumière du soleil
alors qu'on lui demande une énième fois
où se cachent les cités d'or
le guide répète encore plus loin pour
coronado c'en est trop cette fois il
fait exécuter son prisonnier
et nombreux écrivains pense aujourd'hui
que les indigènes invente s légende afin
d'éloigner les espagnols la cité d'or se
trouvait toujours au delà de la colline
suivante
en réalité personne n'a jamais trouvé de
mystérieuses cités d'or admettant son
échec
coronado établi un campement pour
l'hiver en avril 15 142 il commence son
périple pour un retour de 2400 km vers
mexico
ce ne sera pas le dernier des
aventuriers à s'être laisser leurrer par
un mirage
à la fin de l'été 15 192 des corsaires
anglais remonte la tamise escortant leur
butin le madrid hedios un navire
espagnol
sa cale est chargé d'une fortune en
diamant perle épices soi et or
un siècle auparavant les espagnols
avaient battu les anglais pour l'or des
amériques encore leur fallait qu'ils
convoyaient le précieux métal jusque
chez eux ils ont développé un moyen
complexe et ingénieux pour l'acheminer
sur l'atlantique
ce n'était pas chose facile qui plus est
au xvième siècle avec le reste du monde
qui était au courant de leur trafic et
en particulier les pirates anglais
ces flottes lente lourdement chargés en
trésors sont des cibles de choix pour
les corsaires anglais l'ironie du sort
veut que sir walter allègue
l'organisateur de la capture du madre de
dios qui passait alors sa lune de miel à
l'ombre de la fameuse tour de londres
gagne sa libération après avoir dédié un
poème flatteur à la reine elizabeth
une lampe d'or qui lui vaudra de se
tirer d'affaires plus d'une fois vivant
sur le fil du rasoir sur walter allègue
est à la fois un soldat un marin est un
explorateur
en 15 100 95 il lance une expédition en
amérique du sud à la recherche d'une
tribu légendaire de femmes guerrières
les amazones il s'agit également de
ramener de l'or quelques décennies plus
tôt les espagnols ont conquis les
royaumes étincelant des aztèques et des
incas amassant une fortune faite
essentiellement de bibelots et de
parures en or mais des années durant
la provenance même de tout cet or a
continué à leur échapper
ce qui déroutait beaucoup de gens et je
pense que ça explique la légende
eldorado c'est qu'ils avaient autant
d'ornement d'où pouvait venir leur or
certaines histoires raconte qu'une
cérémonie consistait à recouvrir de
poudre d'or l'un des rois présidents à
la religion locale et le faire plonger
dans un bassin sacré j'imagine que les
habitants attendaient qu'il fasse nuit
pour essayer d'aller ensuite glané l'or
ce roi recouvert d'or ainsi que son
royaume scintillant sont tous deux
connus sous le nom générique d'el dorado
une fois de plus quelques européens se
lancent dans une drôle de chasse au
trésor muet par une simple et hasardeuse
les jambes et par leurs rêves démesurés
il est très probable que ces histoires
se soient mélangées et que les
autochtones et d'une manière ou d'une
autre tirer parti de ces légendes pour
tenter de repousser les espagnols de
leur territoire
dix mois après le début de son aventure
au coeur de la jungle guyanaise sur
walter allègue rentrer en angleterre en
15 100 96 avec tout juste une poignée
d'heures
c'est là que sa langue qu'on dit d'or le
tir une fois de plus d'embarras
il parvient à apaiser la colère de sa
reine elizabeth en lui faisant croire
que son portrait a eu pour effet
d'éblouir littéralement les tribunes
hâtives mais à la mort d'elizabeth en
116 103 james premier monte sur le trône
et khaled père les faveurs de la
couronne
on l'accuse même de comploter contre le
roi et on l'enferment dans la tour de
londres
vingt ans plus tard sa passion du métal
jaune est intacte
khaled passe un accord avec le roi james
sur le libère il s'engage à retourner en
guyane pour y dénicher eldorado de
retour en guyane en 16 117 khaled trouve
sur son chemin une colonie espagnole
contre les ordres de james
ils l'attaquent et la pie ix mais la
contre offensive espagnole est si
violente qu'elle pousse les troupes
anglaises à la désertion dorénavant sans
aucun recours possible
khaled rend en angleterre subir son
châtiment
l'homme qui s'avance vers sa propre mort
est un homme malade testant du bout du
doigt le couperet du bourreau ils
lancent dans un ultime trait d'esprit
voilà un remède affûté comme il se doit
propre à guérir tous les maux y compris
ma fièvre pour l'or aura quelque chose
d'excitant qui matérialise l'éternité
et c'est cette sorte de qualité magique
et très mystérieuse qui lui est propre
qui rend les gens fous depuis des
milliers d'années une trahison mortels
une malédiction fatal à la recherche de
la mine perdu du hollandais la mort de
coronado n'a pas pour autant dissipé la
rumeur sur la présence d'or au sud ouest
des états unis
quelques trois cents ans plus tard le
mythique james bowie prend la relève au
texas
la chaîne des montagnes de la
superstition en arizona est l'un des
massifs les mieux nommer du monde
c'est là que des hommes ont été puisées
dans une montagne de mythes leur pépite
d'or et autres grains de vérité des
hommes et des femmes ont accouru des
quatre coins du monde pour chercher de
l'or dans ses montagnes
on a eu comme ça des présidents des
états unis des stars de cinéma ainsi que
toute la palette de la société et de la
culture américaine à venir prospecter
par ici ils croient simplement qu'il ya
de l'or pour eux il faut qu'il y en ait
une croyance qui repose il faut lire sur
une puissante légende l'histoire
obsédante d'un trésor perdu ou vérité et
mythes s'entrelacent inextricablement
tout commence il y a cinq siècles
lorsque coronado parcours le sud-ouest à
la recherche des sept cités d'or après
la conquête espagnole
on a concédé la chaîne des superstitions
à la riche famille pire halte à la
légende veut que trois siècles plus tard
des descendants de cette famille y ai
découvert une fabuleuse mine d'or
les apaches aurait fait en sorte que ces
derniers ne puissent pas récolter les
dividendes de son exploitation
on raconte que quelque part autour de
1847 dans cette zone de gold fields le
champ d'or ou bien là haut dans les
montagnes
il y aurait eu un grand massacre 200 ou
300 mexicains auraient été tuées avec
leurs bourreaux et tous le minerai d'or
aurait été déversé au sol depuis
beaucoup pensent que ces montagnes de la
superstition sont maudites
ceci n'empêche toujours pas cependant
les chercheurs d'or d'espérer retrouver
la fameuse mines en 1877 jacobs un
immigrants allemands et vétérans de la
ruée vers l'or californienne prétend
l'avoir repéré
il n'était pas exagéré de croire que ce
vieil allemand avec les mouches aussi on
a commencé à donner à l'endroit toutes
sortes de noms la mine perdu de jacob la
mine perdu de jake la mine perdu du
hollandais et même la mine du hollandais
perdu personne n'a jamais vu en
possession de plus de quelques pépites
lorsque les apaches du son acolyte world
se quitte définitivement le massif des
superstitions laissant derrière lui de
fascinant indices quant à l'emplacement
exact de la mine
toutes ces indications ont enflammé à
l'époque l'imagination de beaucoup de
gens à la vallée de la rivière salée
ainsi que dans la région de phoenix
parce que c'est là qu'on avait déjà
trouvé pas mal de mine d'or et d'argent
durant des décennies la région continue
de grouiller de chercheurs convoitant la
mystérieuse mines
c'est comme si les chercheurs d'or était
attiré jusqu'ici par l'aspect magnétique
de la mine il y avait comme une fatalité
dans cette attirance quelquefois
d'ailleurs on peut véritablement a
invoqué la fatalité l'un des destins les
plus tragiques et celui d'un vétérinaire
à la retraite du nom d'adolphe run bien
qu'âgé de 65 ans et handicapés
reuze possède un avantage de taille sur
ses concurrents une carte dressée au
mexique qui lui a été transmise par son
fils
cette carte montre est l'emplacement
d'un trésor caché dans la chaîne des
superstitions adolphe run était
convaincu qu en s'y rendant il se
trouverait au printemps 1931 russe en
bouche deux ouvriers agricoles pour
l'accompagner jusque dans les montagnes
après l'avoir aidée à dresser son camp
ils l'abandonnent comme convenu à son
aventure au bout de deux semaines ils
sont revenus en arrière comme il ne les
retrouvait pas ils ont envoyé un petit
détachement le chercher mais on ne
trouve aucune trace de ross et ont fini
par abandonner les recherches
ce n'est que sept mois plus tard que des
archéologues en chantier dans les
superstitions font une macabre
découverte
l'un de leurs chiens de meute a flairé
un crâne sous ce palo verde qui
s'avérait être celui d'adolf russe il y
avait un trou en plein milieu dont le
docteur alex du national museum de
washington a déclaré qu'il provenait
d'une balle de calibre 44
mais les autorités d'arizona ont
contredit cette version en préférant
affirmé qu'ils étaient morts de chaleur
et d'épuisement suite à un état probable
de pro sternum en la vérité sur les
conditions de sa mort demeure un mystère
toujours est il que cette histoire
insuffle une nouvelle énergie dans la
légende de la mine perdu
de nos jours des chasseurs d'or continue
de se poser dans la région ayant fait le
voeu d'en percer le secret trouvez la
mine de ce hollandais perdu revient à
résoudre une énigme extrêmement complexe
si je pouvais moi même solutionner ces
indices un parent je pourrai enfin
découvrir où elle se cache
je ne sais pas combien dommages et m'ont
dit la même rengaine
si seulement je pouvais répondre à ceux
ci et puis à cela si seulement on me
laissait encore un an ou même un mois
certains sur leur lit de mort on dit si
seulement je pouvais sortir d'ici ne
serait ce qu'une seule journée je suis
sûr de l'avoir à la recherche d'une
tombe perdu est la rançon en or d'un roi
d'un point de vue géologique
il y a très peu de chances pour qu'un
riche dépôt d'or existe dans les
montagnes de la superstition
alors qu'à quelques kilomètres de là
seulement dans le désert la mine du
mammouth a permis d'extraire pour
environ 3 millions de dollars en or dans
les années 1890
des pyramides égyptiennes à gizeh le
cimetière le plus célèbre du monde
c'est là que sont enterrés les pharaons
et leur fortune en or dans des tombes
scellé pour l'éternité ou du moins le
pense et il vous savez les égyptiens
croyait dans une vie après la mort
cette seconde vie était essentiel pour
eux c'est là qu'ils allaient demeurer
cette fois pour l'éternité
voilà pourquoi on construisait les
tombes à l'intérieur de pyramide pour
préserver le lieu de résidence de leur
vie après la mort
si les tombes des pharaons résiste aux
ravages de dame nature
il succombe en revanche aux dégradations
perpétrées par le genre humain
trois mille ans plus tard dans la vallée
des rois des archéologues s'attelle à
déterrer les pharaons en espérant exhumé
leurs reliques en or mais ils
s'aperçoivent que les voleurs de
l'époque sont déjà passés par là
savez vous que j'ai trouvé ce cimetière
absolument intacts vous savez pourquoi
parce qu'il ne renferme pas d'or
les gens qui sont étaient très pauvres
ils ne pouvaient pas se permettre
d'emmener de l'or dans leurs tombes
ça n'intéresse donc pas les voleurs au
début du 20e siècle
les archéologues ont presque perdu tout
espoir de retrouver la sépulture d'un
pharaon et ses trésors intacte nous à
l'automne 1917 un égyptologue
britannique du nom de howard carter
commencent à s'intéresser à la tombe
d'un pharaon de moindre importance que
l'histoire ignore encore et que
l'archéologie a négligé jusqu'ici cet
enfant roi mort vers 13 150 avant
jésus-christ pendant son adolescence
n'est autre que toutankhamon le roi tut
le nic obstacles s'opposant au projet de
carter qui consiste à effectuer des
fouilles très approfondie et le manque
d'argent il parvient à trouver un
commanditaire en la personne de car
narbonne un riche lord anglais expatriés
en egypte pour raisons de santé et
amoureux d'archéologie
les cinq premières années de travail
coûte une fortune sans succès car
narbonne s'apprête à lui couper les
vivres
vous savez sa découverte de la tombe du
roi tout est tout à fait extraordinaire
carter avait perdu tout espoir de la
trouver un jour d'ailleurs lors du
carnaval l'avait prévenu vous effectuez
la votre dernière saison dans la toute
dernière section à être creusé un
ouvrier mais tout à coup au jour une
première marche de pierre
elle mène un passage souterrain marqué
du sceau de la royauté carter découvre
avec horreur que le célé a été réparé ce
qui prouve qu'on sait déjà introduits
dans les lieux
on avait violé la tombe du roi tout les
voleurs s'y était glissé pour y dérober
des objets voilà pourquoi ils l'ont
trouvé son insu dessous au delà de
l'entrée c'est les carters s'attend à
mettre les pieds dans une tombe pillés
mais il s'est déjà avancée trop loin
pour pouvoir reculer la nuit du 26
novembre 1922
son commanditaire pencher par dessus son
épaule carter s'emploie à désobstruer
délicatement l'entrée de la tombe
il a ouvert un trou et a regardé à
travers le lors de lui a demandé ce
qu'ils voyaient et carter a répondu des
choses magnifiques
c'était à cause de l'éclat de l'or à
l'intérieur de la salle
les précédents intrus avaient dû être
pris sur le fait la tombe est en
désordre mais rien n'a été pillés à
l'intérieur il trouve un acte près de
quatre mille trésors 12 plus éblouissant
les uns que les autres à tristouille et
si vous regardiez dans cette tombe
c'était plein d'or partout le seul
sarcophage représentait plus de 100
kilos d'or on ne peut pas vraiment
s'imaginer la quantité d'or de renfermer
cette tombe
l'egypte était un pays riche en métal
jaune
lorsqu'on était un homme important ou
bien un grand pharaon comme toutankhamon
il était de coutume de se faire enterrer
au milieu de magnifiques objets en or
dans un sarcophage lui-même en or à
l'intérieur du sarcophage repose tout le
visage caché sous l'un des plus grands
chefs-d'oeuvre qui soit un masque
mortuaire en or massif
je pense que quiconque a vu ce masque
mortuaire et les autres merveilles qui
l'accompagnait n'a probablement jamais
oublier la pression qu'il a ressenti
si vous avez l'occasion de le voir lors
d'une exposition vous y serez peut être
confronté au détour d'une salle
il sera là présenté à l'abri d'une
vitrine c'est spectaculaire
vous serez projeté devant une
personnalité ayant vécu il ya 3000 ou
4000 ans
le tombeau de toutankhamon constitue la
plus riche découverte d'objets en or de
l'histoire de l'archéologie
5000 objets vous rendez compte de
l'importance de la découverte et qui
plus est des objets en or
pendant les deux années qui suivent
carter est à pied d'oeuvre dans la
vallée des rois
il enlève une à une de la sépulture les
magnifiques choses telles qu'il les a
décrites au premier coup d'oeil
c'est aussi une période qu'il passe à se
quereller avec le gouvernement égyptien
sur sa part légitime du trésor un jour
dans un accès de dépit il referme la
tombe
les égyptiens réplique en le déportant
purement et simplement un an plus tard
il est autorisé à revenir sous condition
qu'il renonce à revendiquer quoi que ce
soit du butin pas une seule miette de sa
splendide découverte ne lui reviendra
la quête d'un trésor englouti à la suite
d'une vague de décès parmi les visiteurs
on pense que la tombe de tubes et
maudite des scientifiques désigneront
plus tard le vrai coupable
un champignon qui couvent depuis des
siècles dans la tombe scellé
chaque jour les bateaux naviguant au
large du détroit de floride transporte
une marchandise dont la valeur n'a
atteint qu'une infime partie de celles
des trésors engloutis sous les flots les
épaves de milliers de galions espagnols
gisent éparpillés sur les fonds sous
marins
près d'elle repose une inestimable
fortune en or il existe une chasse
permanente au trésor en particulier aux
caraïbes
mais partout ailleurs aussi dès lors
qu'il ya eu un naufrage
ces navires transportait des pièces d'or
voir des barres d'or
[Musique]
l'île au trésor et le plus grand récit
du genre c'est lui qui en le marquant à
jamais va inspirer amel fischer un gars
de ligne viana sa longue chasse au
trésor en floride depuis tout petit il a
toujours été passionné par la chasse au
trésor c'est quelque chose qu'il avait
toujours rêvé de faire mais elle grandit
et des ménages vers l'état doré de
californie c'est là qu'il entame ses
recherches il avait commencé par prendre
magasin de plongée il s'est mis à
économiser de l'argent en même temps
qu'il laissait libre cours à ses chasses
aux trésors qui n'était encore qu'un
hobby peu à peu au début des années 60
il a décidé d'en faire sa principale
activité le magot que convoi de fisher
une flotte de galion espagnol coulé au
large des côtes de floride en 1715
il revend son affaire attrape femmes et
enfants et s'embarque pour la péninsule
en retenant son souffle on s'est mis
d'accord avec six autres personnes pour
se donner un an de travail sans gagner
quoi que ce soit l'équipe de fischer va
balayer quelque 193 milles kilomètres
linéaires de fonds sous marins à l'aide
d'un détecteur de métaux appelé
magnétomètre un appareil capable de
repérer un canon une encre ou bien de
l'or le 360e jour soit cinq jours avant
la fin de leur deal ils ont creusé un
trou qui s'est avéré être remplies de
doublons en or ce jour béni ils
remonteront pour une valeur de 50 mille
dollars en or
fischer en devient complètement accro
deux ans plus tard il commence à passer
au peigne fin le chapelet d'îles des
florida keys son ambition vise à l'eau
encore plus impressionnant le galion
espagnol atocha les espagnols rassembler
le butin piller aux amériques et les
acheminer à bord de flotte plus légères
vers la havane à cuba
c'était un peu leur plaque tournante
c'est là que les navires convergaient
sous la forme d'une flotte imposante
avant d'embarquer vers l'espagne cet
incroyable flot de richesse le processus
a duré comme ça plus de 300 ans
des dizaines de ces navires convoyeur de
trésors deviennent la proie de corsair
de cape et d'épée
tél soeur francis drake et soeurs walter
allègue c'était ses pièces d'or idrac a
leg et d'autres convoité il ya 400 ans
mais la pire menace ce ne sont pas les
pirates
c'est le temps
lorsque la torche à hisser les voiles en
août 722 la saison des ouragans a déjà
commencé un jour après leur départ de la
havane
ils ont été pris dans un ouragan
l'amiral a ordonné à sa flotte de mettre
le cap sur l'ouest en pensant qu'il
pourrait dépasser la région floridienne
des cases et étaler la tempête comme on
dit dans le jargon dans le golfe du
mexique
en définitive tous les navires qui ont
suivi leur amiral ont coulé corps et
biens alors que tous ceux qui ont
désobéi à ses ordres s'en sont sortis
la tempête fait plus de 500 victimes
parmi les navires voué à leur faim
figure le plus chargé en or la tâche à
chacune de ces cargaisons en nord
d'amérique du sud vers l'espagne
représentait une quantité d'or colossal
par rapport à ceux qui circulaient dans
le monde
si pour une raison quelconque elle
n'arrivait pas à bon port
ça voulait dire que des armées ne
recevrait pas leurs soldes qu'elle ne
pouvait plus nourrir 7 est absolument
capital pour l'espagne cela faisait
quatre ans qu'il n'y avait plus un seul
acheminement de trésor vers l'espagne
l'euro avait désespérément besoin de cet
argent
et lorsque la touche à a coulé ça a eu
un effet dévastateur sur l'économie du
pays
en 1970 mail fischer part à la recherche
de la taupe chars
il en a entendu parler en lisant le
guide potter de la pêche au trésor à
côté du galion figuraient quatre étoiles
en rapport avec la valeur de sa
cargaison
on savait par exemple que 47 tonnes d'or
et d'argent nous attendait notre étude
nous a ensuite permis de le localiser
du moins approximativement le point de
départ en question et le nord des
florida keys mais sur place leurs
recherches ne les mène à rien quatre ans
plus tard lundi ce clés leur apparaît de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique d'entre les
pages poussiéreuse d'archivés conserver
à séville 1 enquêteurs chargés de
fouiller les vieux papiers réalise tout
à coup que fisher ne prospectait pas au
bon endroit
il a passé trois ans à explorer pour
rien la zone des matches 15 au nord des
florida keys il se trouvait 160km trop
loin ça veut dire aussi que son guide
potter n'avait pas fourni de bonnes
informations
fischer transfère sa base à key west et
reprend à zéro tout aussi optimiste
qu'il se retrouve à court d'argent
il embarque sa famille à bord d'une
maison flottante qui prend l'eau ils
affrontent les sociétés de recouvrement
il revend les petits trésors qu'ils
glanent afin de pouvoir continuer à
chercher celui qui se dérobe encore à sa
convoitise
sans perdre la foi ils annoncent chaque
matin son équipe
aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour
seize années durant avec une même est
infaillible volonté fischer traque lato
de chat le coût des recherches est
devenu faramineux en 1975
l'un de nos bateaux de sauvetage a
chaviré et mon frère et sa femme ainsi
qu'un autre plongeur sont restés coincés
à l'intérieur et sont morts noyés
on a alors pensé tout arrêter mais on
s'est dit que dirk aurait aimé qu'on
continue et ça a renforcé notre
détermination
il fallait en quelque sorte qu'on le
trouve rien que pour dirk et c'est
précisément le jour du 10e anniversaire
de l'accident qu'on l'a trouvé
j'ai tendance à penser qu'il était là
nos côtés le 19 juillet 1985 mail
fischer annonce comme d'habitude
aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour à l'aide
de magnétomètres et d'un sonar ses fils
kim et kane passent la journée à
ratisser le fonds à la recherche d'un
indice sur la dodge à cet après-midi la
kahina n'ont soudain qu'il a trouvé
quelque chose
il m'a appelé par radio pour me signaler
que le coup qu'on venait de marquer
indiqué des cercles de tonneaux qui
dépassait de la vase
il s'agissait en fait de bandes
métalliques qui servait à maintenir
assembler les fûts d'eau douce ça
commençait à être passionnant alors que
le soleil baisse qu'a eu mme fisher
décide de replonger pour examiner la
chose de plus près il a creusé un trou
c'était plein de cercles de tonneaux la
pièce de 8 comme la pièce d'argent que
je porte et de lingots de cuivre
la touche a transporté 20 tonnes de
cuivre
c'était de mieux en mieux on a déplacé
un peu le bateau et on a recommencé à
creuser et y avait moins de trucs et un
peu plus loin encore moins on a commencé
à se demander si on ne s'était pas
encore gentiment fait avoir la tâche à
nous a mené en bateau plusieurs fois
à la nuit tombante les frères sont
contraints de stopper leurs recherches
le lendemain matin ils déplacent encore
leur bateau et creuse un nouveau trou
cette fois il tape en plein dans le
mille
ma première réaction a été de me
demander ce que j'allais faire
maintenant qu'un navire qui avait
monopolisé l'essentiel de ma vie se
trouvait juste à ma portée mon
hésitation n'a pas duré longtemps pour
le trouver
ça a été toute une autre histoire mais
c'était intéressant en tout les
phisheurs remonte à la surface
nettoie et répertorie 250 mille objets
des bars d'argent des lingots d'or des
maîtres de chaînes en or on estime la
valeur de la marchandise retrouvée à un
demi milliard de dollars la découverte
fait de fischer le chasseur de trésor le
plus riche du monde
et attise l'avidité des autorités de
l'état
l'état de floride et le gouvernement
fédéral ont tous deux revendiqué la
propriété du trésor mon père le rhône a
proposé 35 % ils ont refusé parce qu'ils
en voulaient la totalité on a été en
procès pendant huit ans et ça s'est
terminé devant la cour suprême des
etats-unis qui le trouve le gard dont il
jugeait on a donc plutôt garder à la
suite de quoi mail fischer retourne en
mer approfondir encore si recherche
il décède d'un cancer à 76 ans en 1998
papa est resté un chasseur de trésors du
tout premier au dernier jour de sa vie
il est mort heureux pour ma part je ne
vois pas ce que je pourrais faire de
mieux
j'y consacrerai le reste de ma vie moi
aussi
comme tous les autres chasseurs d'or de
coronado à carter et à l'instar de son
père fischer vie sous l'emprise du
fascinant métal
le synthé l'or a une particularité on en
devient très vite dépendants même après
avoir séjourné trois cent soixante-cinq
ans sous les eaux ils en ressortent
aussi brillant qu'au jour du naufrage
il ne ternit pas ils ne roulent pas
c'est un métal tout bonnement superbe
éblouissant éclatant
c'est de l'or qui brille chacun des
objets constituant les trésors de la
ccia reflète l'obsession séculaire de
l'homme pour le métal jaune
plusieurs siècles avant colons les incas
creux ce même or afin de créer de quoi
embellir leur vie quotidienne
c'est alors que les conquistadors
débarque et livrent bataille pour s'en
emparer
laruns cas devient l'argent liquide qui
fait tourner le monde et quand l'or a le
malheur de couler au fond des océans
le rêve prend alors la relève
on est revenu en quelque sorte au point
de départ ce qui séduisait les gens il y
a cinq six ou sept siècles c'était de
savoir qu'il pouvait transformer ce
métal qu'il trouvait magnifique en
ornement tout aussi magnifique
c'est exactement ce qui se passe de nos
jours on en fait des parures que les
gens portent sur eux aux quatre coins du
monde
quelque chose de si attrayant que les
hommes sont capables de tenter le sort
pour s'en saisir
il est impossible de penser à l'or et à
son véritable rôle dans la vie de
l'histoire sans se remémorer une
merveilleuse anecdotes racontées par
john ruskin à la fin de l'époque
victorienne
il s'agit d'un homme à bord d'un navire
qui effectue une traversée retour vers
l'est une énorme tempête fait rage sur
l'océan et le bateau commence à couler
la larme donne le signal d'abandonner le
bâtiment est cet homme qui rentre avec
toute sa fortune dans un sac d'or la
trappe et saute par dessus bord
évidemment comme l'or est un métal lourd
l'homme coule à pic
ruskin pose alors la question est ce
qu'il a eu lors ou bien est-ce que c'est
lors qu'il l'a eu